hey guys I'm Ryan right hi guys I'm
Veronica we got sent this I know there's
a lot of cringe compilations out there
I've never actually taken time to watch
one we got sent cringe compilation 2015
my GF and I get a kick out of
compilations yes video yes compilations
that we have assembled ourselves just
takes of her and I don't worry there'll
be a montage video up soon let's do this
click every sentence there's a sex
reference you this is a kids party nice
the most guys smear them RMS alright
yeah I'm gonna teach you some moves on
lay this dish did did GT it is P I can
do that
Oh
by Unanimous Consent
Josh you will be going into the nerd-off
this is great the least intelligent
member of my team is Josh he has similar
gamer skills to me but he doesn't have
the entire rest of cornucopia
information I have I think they know me
the hardest working player in this team
is now so if I'm to sit back and watch
the entertainment like watching a bunch
of Dan cybers and by the way so
subscribe thank you but you are a
redundancy in our program and because I
know every Pokemon you know plus I get
some popcorn I have an IQ 146 I can
absorb the world as I see it I did
everything they just completed my vision
Katie what do you think I'm really
really glad I'm on this team love it oh
yeah
Wow Wow he's making the blob left you
are - call security you can fill out the
form just like everybody else s okay I
mean I'm just waiting to talk to someone
a lot for asking though under sitting
here until somebody's available
it's her answer yes it is would you like
me to call campus security I will do
okay
people very many toys you find a video
and except wouldn't make many people
even though no watches my videos oh oh
oh
McDonald I've been practicing and I
think electric buzz saw that a compass a
few of you later goodbye busy south
chubby bunny train look at me but oh my
god I'm good and I smell chocolate they
economy this is a cart in Fell's going
up off the video now they call me Lily
hi folks this is Jed a blue a cave frog
or I'm here to talk to you about my
little poem of longing 3 which is being
kick-started right now what is my new
poem oh well many of you already know
since this is the third form so um if
you see me do this skip to that point
that's where I start talking about this
specific volume those of you who don't
know what it is here's a quick recap
my little poem Oh is a blog project I
started about two years ago the goal was
to analyze every episode of My Little
Pony Friendship is Magic until I caught
up with the series I accomplished that
goal back in January she wish she wishes
I was to avoid president Kickstarter's
we got a waiver now up top having him
come up stress tie up right now top
straight up let's go man right there
yeah
no man that's not much of an answer top
you [ __ ] I think you cute oh he's
good Joe man and poppy market sake but
it is such a professional man and I
thought you know I'm sorry like you know
I think you feel from collection right
now [ __ ] them when right you know
what the [ __ ] over I'm good this
ain't no nice middle cliche does good to
all calm
oh wait sugar free cuz I like the head
girl trailer right now for fallout 4
give me a second
my gosh I'm the graphic zone no way I am
on the channel new route he needs to
guest star on this show doc me you still
my back oh my god the line
oh my god it look - don't good it looks
so good what the baby creation want to
contact notifications oh it's beautiful
being the baby
I remember trailers nuclear detonation
oh its pre-war oh it's showing your
reward my love it's gotta be on the gym
oh my god like the last guy a lot I
thought he was fantastic you should try
to contact him oh my god I know where
he's from it was a hilarious reaction
he was so genuine - what was so adorable
about it huh I want to know who that guy
is yeah I would love to have that guy
this channel he's so [ __ ] funny this
wasn't really cringe-worthy I laughed a
lot but nothing really made me cringe I
think what it means by cringe is that
they're just all awkward I know but I
wanted to see like a guy skating on a
pole and he hit this crotch like Oh
Randy that's a great hey that's what a
cringe is I feel sorry for the first
people the Toy Story guys why do you
feel sorry for them because how what a
humiliating gig it looks like they were
having a good ass time I mean they look
like that you can't see their face I bet
underneath its depression alcohol you
have no clue though it looked like they
were having more fun than the actual
little kids that they were performing
for because little kids were freaked out
the [ __ ] Woody and Buzz were doing
like like Drake dancing man it was
horrible it was horrible I don't know
what that reality show was what about
the Nerds that was [ __ ] hilarious you
know I've been once in a while I meet
like a true nerd or a true geek like
it's very rare where I do when I do
they're like the most fascinating human
being on the planet
everyone found nerds to be attractive um
babe
heavy sometimes yeah actually yeah they
get you oh I wouldn't say that I just
remember from a young age like some
every once in a while I would be have a
crush on someone that was kind of nerdy
you ever hooked up with a nerd that's
why I kind of like you in your glasses
actually I really like the humors
that's fantastic have you ever hooked up
with nerd Abbi yeah Oh what what do you
mean hooked up I just made out with them
who my next-door neighbor our next-door
neighbor no my old next-door neighbor in
high school all through high school we
were neighbors and then he moved and I
moved in no last day we just decided to
make a home how how old are you 19 19
that wasn't that long ago so what I know
why do you let me inquire about your
past sexual experiences you know I don't
handle it well
I love the prank of the guy looking at
all the cheap items
wow what a low price it takes a certain
kind of balls to do that sort of thing
in public you know it takes balls to be
too hugely overweight women who are
doing chubby bunny I found that one
actually extremely sad I was really sad
that's like very very sad that's like
them I guess embracing their weight but
it's also extremely unhealthy but that's
kind of funny it's a huge they are yeah
it's a little funny but they're doing
chubby bunny and they're like 400 pounds
that's funny that's like class a comedy
I would watch like I would do a full
reaction in that video you seem to be
really bothered by the guy who was
hitting on the dudes girlfriend ah so
annoying
have you gotta people hit on you like
that yeah like that no whatever anyway
he's going like that you're hooked up
with a guy like that no no never like oh
really oh really
no not just to protect my feelings I do
not like when guys holler what if they
were like physically beautiful like what
if like Ryan Gosling was hollering no I
don't care it looks with me sure what if
he knew it was Ryan Gosling and he was
talking to me like that
probably not know what turn off big
turtle I would let Ryan Gosling talk to
me I'd let Ryan Gosling talk to you like
that anyway guys thanks for tuning in to
the channel you can click this button
right here to subscribe and become a
rejected a pushing youtuber naming
people whatever Veronica she's a musical
artist does a lot of acoustic covers
check it out and she also does vlogs to
follow us on our social networks trying
to get more product placement I wanted
to take this opportunity to tell
everyone the truth about my penis size
it is medium but the width is good I've
been told it is thick everyone wanted to
know and now you know that I get the
thick comment a lot you don't see it you
never want to see it we've been together
for over a year you still have you're
really getting on my nerves at least see
one nipple